[Musik]
hey ich bin blogger meine damen und
herren
deswegen das ist das mein aufnahme zum
habe ich übrigens als gc bittet herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen blog
meine damen und herren das jeder dass
sein einziger freund ihr seht schon da
hinten stehen ein paar sachen hier
packen wir gerade unsere sachen da ist
jude übrigens wir fahren heute nach
hause nach bielefeld zu meiner familie
weil ich heute abend dort auf einer
party auflege
das bereits im titel eingeblendet und
ich machen häuser eine tim kaine
challenge ich weiß noch nicht genau
worum es dabei geht aber es handelt sich
dabei irgendwie so darum dass man sich
im supermarkt ein paar verschiedene
dosen kaufen mit verschiedenem essen
drin also beispielsweise mit etwas
leckeres zu essen oder mit was
ekelhaften und dann werden die teile mit
ich wir fahren erst mal nach hause
wir sind so aus dem video feld freunde
herzlich willkommen jule und luca in
würm agile business am telefonieren wir
müssen fans kaufen also dosen für die
teen challenge essen essen essen essen
essen essen feuerlöscher essen essen
essen essen der traum eines jeden
spielers allerdings gerade nicht da sind
ja eigentlich allerdings war die
überraschung gesehen hat einkaufen im
supermarkt und haben uns wie viel nutzen
immer gekauft und will man schlechte
zähne hälfte hälfte an gewehrt jetzt die
etiketten abreißen und dann sehen wir
uns bei der linken stellt wieder heim
edel wie haben sie heute versammelt weil
wir eine tin cans challenge machen dafür
haben wir hier schon verschiedene dosen
im supermarkt gekauft und die haben eine
beschriftung 417 a unter diesen hack
dosenfutter teilen befinden sich vier
sachen die relativ lecker sind wie
beispielsweise 740 oder so haben wir
drin allerdings sind doch sachen die
juler hast meisten da damit auch glaube
ich so sellerie scheiße irgendwie aber
auf jeden fall rechteckigen schnitt
gekauft hier und wir haben jetzt hier
auf jeden fall die acht zahlen drauf
stehen das heißt beziehen abwechselnd
eine zarte diese person muss damit
verbundenen augen aus diesem ding
heimischen kosten die chancen bei mir
stehen jetzt auf 50 50 ich habe die zahl
6 das heißt ich weiß nicht was ihr von
36 ist aber ich verbinde jetzt mal die
augen auf juli folgte direkt gewesen
also die sechstes werk meine damen und
herren das heißt juli die chance größer
dass er das macht ihr da macht jeder
muss jetzt seine augen zu halten oder
will sich nicht meine box auf den kopf
setzen deswegen sich die augen zu
kommen wir nun zu julis situation ihre
sie gezogen hat
nein ich dachte das wäre kräfte zwiebeln
so sieht das einfach aus
das wären so ekelhaft kleine vergammelte
zwiebel nächstes länder sich in sieben
freunde das heißt dass das jetzt mal auf
dass die das denken dass hier was ist
das
lulus zweite essen ist das hier freunde
schauen gekommen
[Musik]
möhren malta ich habe jedes nächste
freunde das heißt ich wieder eine nummer
und wir haben für mich die nummer eins
da passt zu mir
immer wieder geht die familie und videos
an beispiel das ist so egal ob die tat
um und fragen da so egeler was ich noch
finde was richtig klar geht sind zu
verlegen oder so gebratene champignons
unterfangen aber die die sind einfach
gelebt bericht und stinken und wir haben
noch drei wuchsen hier rumstehen juli
zieht einen zettel und hat als nummer
acht
als nächstes haben wir hier für juli das
hier ja und ich kriege sellerie scheiße
- und manchmal sogar ihre vorletzte dose
meine damen und herren
ich habe nummer drei also eine von
diesen beiden dosen hier wird sein
juli werde jetzt nur noch eines übrig
das heißt ich sage schon mal 100 ist
deutlich dass man hier einen dass ihr
bekommt julia jetzt zu essen
[Musik]
kirche ist ein schattenmorellen steht
dir keiner wusste was ich dachte dass
wir ihn noch ekelhaftes ich hab noch nie
den begriff schattenmorellen gehört der
speck ihr schon geil aber ist ja auch
egal meine damen und herren ich dachte
auf jeden fall nicht meine wer von euch
kennt dem golfstaat moritz schreiben in
die kommentare ob wir den begriff
schattenmorellen kennen weil ich dachte
das wäre irgendwie sowas wie so datteln
oder irgend so ein scheiß wenn er diese
tim kaine channels gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen leid daher im juli und
ich sind übrig sie jetzt zu hause weil
ich heute abend auf einer party auflege
die möhre hoch allerdings warte jetzt
erst mal noch auf hin
das ist so ein spaß titeln etwa schönen
guten tag hallo im block einmal einen
glückskeks aufzeigen was draufsteht
das war die haben jetzt gerade nur was
man chinesen geholt das auch gegessen
habt ja gegen glückskeks und die
botschaft und filmen gesehen allerdings
ist es jetzt auch schon ein bisschen
dunkel draußen geworden und wir fragen
jetzt wird party wo ich zum eigentlich
dritten mal auf läge aber zum ersten mal
vom bisschen mehr als 50 leuten das
heißt ihr seht jetzt irgendwelche snap
einblendungen die boxen waren komplett
beschissen eingestellt also wenn dann
wissen vom hören die eigentlich wirklich
komplett schrott ich habe mein bestes
gegeben aber darüber wollen wir nicht
reden sondern über den heutigen lockt
meine damen und hin und natürlich diese
team challenge heute gefallen hat das
gerne bei einem like da ich glaube ich
habe gerade die ganze zeit diese stifte
das leicht da jetzt euch gefallen hat
und wenn dich in den lassen hätten
dislike da ist meine hose das ist eine
lampe das ist fußball und hey schau
[Musik]